الخبر العاجل قائد القوات ال الجويه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط يقول ان قواتنا
الجويه شنت ضربات ضد 60 هدفا في 16 موقعا
تابعا للحوثيين مزيد من التفاصيل
فادي نعم المعطيات المتلاحقه بدات تكشف عن
عمليه عسكريه لا يمكن وصفها الا
بالواسطات قائد القوات الجويه الامريكيه
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الذي قال ان ال
الوات الامريكيه في تلك المنطقه وفي
عمومها حقيقه واستخدمت اكثر او نحو 100
صاروخ من طرز مختلفه استهدفت 60
هدفا في 16 موقعا تابعا لانصار الله
الحوثيين في اليمن وهذه المواقع تنوعت من
مراكز القياده والسيطره ومخازن السلاح
ورادارات انظمه الدفاع الجوي فضلا عن
الصواريخ ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي المسؤول
قال ان جرى استخدام في هذه الضربات منصات
مختلفه واطلقت صواريخ توما هوك من
الغواصات وايضا من السفن العسكريه البحريه
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه كانت نشرت بيانا
ارفقته بمشاهد اكدت ما كنا نقلناه نقلا عن
المسؤولين الامريكيين بان الولايات
المتحده استخدمت حامله الطائرات
ايزنهاور حيث بينت هذه المشاهد انطلاق
طائرات اف 18 من على متن الحامله ايزنهاور
والتي هي موجوده قباله سواحل اليمن كما
اشار لنا مسؤول امريكي الى ان الولايات
المتحده استخدمت في هذا القصف الواسع
غواصه فلوريدا المزوده بصواريخ كروز والتي
دخلت المنطقه في نوفمبر الماضي في ظل
التوتر ال منسوب التوتر المرتفع على خلفيه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه قائد
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه كان له بيان
لافت وتصريحات لافته للغايه اشار فيها الى
ان الولايات المتحده سوف تحاسب الحوثيين
ورعاته الايرانيين وفق تعبيره جراء
تهديداتهم المتواصله
للملاحه في منطقه البحر الاحمر في حين
اشار قائد القوات الجويه في القياده في
الشرق الاوسط الى ان هذه القوات ملتزمه
بشركائها في تلك المنطقه وملتزمه بالتصدي
للميليشيات
المدعومه من ايران وفق تعبيره بما فيه
المتمردون الحوثيون وفق تعبير المسؤولين
الامريكيين الولايات المتحده عمليا
استخدمت اسلحه مختلفه من الطائرات من
السفن الموجوده في المنطقه من الغواصات
تحديدا غواصه فلوريدا وهي من طراز اوهايو
وضربت مواقع تتعلق بمراكز اطلاق الصواريخ
الصواريخ البالستيه مخازنها الصواريخ كروز
التي يستخدمها الحوثيون في هجماته
والوقائع ايضا تكشف ان هذا القرار بشن هذه
الضربات كان عمليا اتخذه الرئيس بايدن يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي لا سما بعد الهجوم الواسع
الذي شنه انصار الله الحوثيون مستخدمين
مسيرات وصواريخ كروز وصاروخ بالستي واحد
مضاد
للسفن وفق الرئيس بايدن هذا الهجوم كان
يستهدف سفنا حربيا ويوم الخميس اعطى
الاشاره النهائيه والامر النهائي بتوجيه
هذه الضربات مسؤولون امريكيون راعون في
البيت الابيض تحديدا في مجلس الامن القومي
اشاروا الى ان هذه الهجمات التي حصلت يوم
الثلاثاء كانت سوف تصيب سفن امريكيه وكان
بجوارها سفن حربيه امريكيه بما فيها ايضا
سفينه كانت تحمل وقودا للطائرات لكن تمكنت
السفن الحربيه الامريكيه من التصدي لهذا
الهجوم اكد المسؤولون الامريكيون انهم لا
يسعون الى التص ولكن كما اشار الرئيس
الامريكي واشار وزير الدفاع ان الولايات
المتحده ستتخذ الاجراءات الضروريه لحمايه
قواتها بمواجهه اي تهديد او رد فعل عسكري
من قبل الحوثيين وكان مسؤول امريكي قال
لنا الى ان الهجمات التي جار شنها على
مواقع انصار الله الحوثيين جاءت في موجات
متتابعه وفي اوقات مختلفه واخذت في عين
الاعتبار امكانيه تو وجيه ضربات اخرى
متتابعه خصوصا في حال جاءت ردود عسكريه من
داخل اليمن من داخل المواقع حيث يوجد
انصار الله الحوثيون ضد مواقع امريكيه
مختلفه سواء في البحر الاحمر او في
المنطقه ومنح قائد القياده الوسطى الجنرال
كوريلا مساحه واسعه من المرونه لاتخاذ
الاجراءات كما يراها متناسبه في توجيه هذه
الضربات وايضا في اقتناص الفرص في حال
تمكنت القوات الامريكيه من رصد اي اهداف
لم تكن ضمن لائحتها يمكن استهدافها في كل
الاحوال الاداره الامريكيه تؤكد ان ما جرى
هو اجراء دفاعي للدفاع عن الامريكيين وعن
السفن الامريكيه والعالميه للدفاع عن
التجاره العالميه في تلك المنطقه وان كل
ما حصل لا علاقه له بالحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه لكن كان لافتا في كل بيان
صدر وفي كل موقف صدر ح حرص الاداره
الامريكيه على تحميل ايران المسؤوليه عن
دعمها لانصار الله الحوثييين وهجماتهم في
البحر الاحمر سواء من خلال تقديم المعطيات
الاستخباراتيه او المقدرات العسكريه او
الحرص على وصف انصار الله الحوثيين بانهم
مدعومون من ايران في كل بيان نعم